هذا موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره اقتحمت
مجموعه من المستوطنين صباح اليوم المسجد
الاقصى بحمايه قوات الاحتلال التي انتشرت
بكثافه في المنطقه وقالت مراسله الجزيره
ان نحو 400 مستوطن اقتحموا الاقصى في 9
مجموعه
[موسيقى]
هذا وقد اعتدت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
على شبان فلسطينيين عند باب الاسباط
ومنعتهم بالقوه من دخول المسجد الاقصى
لاداء صلاه الفجر كما منعت قوه الاحتلال
عشرات النساء من الدخول ايضا الى المسجد
اغلق عشرات الفلسطينيين ابواب المصلى
القبلي في المسجد الاقصى المبارك من
الداخل قبيل انتهاء الصلاه التراويح وقد
اكد المعتكفون انهم اغلقوا الابواب
للحيلوله دون تمكن قوات الاحتلال من
اقتحام المسجد واخراجهم بالقوه
الا وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي انه اصدر
اوامر لاتخاذ خطوات فوريه في عقاب الهجمات
الارهابيه على حد وصفه واعلن غالنتا في
تغريده ان الجيش سيدعم وحدات الشرطه حيثما
كان الامر ضروريا واضاف ان اغلاق المعابر
مع الضفه الغربيه وغزه سيستمر حتى نهايه
عيد الفصحى كما امر باستدعاء اربع سرايا
احتياط من حرس الحدود
اعلنت البحريه الامريكيه انها ارسلت الى
الشرق الاوسط الغواصه us فلوريدا التي
تعمل بالطاقه النوويه والمزوده بصواريخ
موجهه لدعم الاسطول الخامس الذي يتخذ من
البحرين مقرا له وقالت ميثي هوكينز
المتحدث باسم البحريه ان الغواصه قادره
على حمل ما يصل الى 154 صاروخ كروزه من
طراز توماهوك مضيفا انها ارسلت للمساعده
في نشر الامن البحري في المنطقه ونقلت
صحيفه
ان الاداره الامريكيه تلقت معلومات تفيد
بان ايران تخطط لتنفيذ هجمات في المنطقه
قريبا
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]